we are very close to 10,000 subscribers to
the David Pakman show, subreddit at davidpakman.com/
R. E. D. D. I. T. A lot of great stuff there.
I want to point out a few interesting threads
I spotted this morning. One is a viewer who
says, is David religious? David's sure talks
a lot about being Jewish, but I'm disappointed
that someone as intelligent as him. May actually
believe in the religious nonsense of Abrahamic
religions. No, I'm not religious. As I've
said before, I'm ethnically Jewish, 100% according
to my, uh, ancestry.com and 23 and me DNA
tests. If you don't, uh, if some people don't
know that Judaism is an ethno religious group,
it, there is an ethnicity and there is a religion.
If you are ethnically Jewish, you can believe
or not believe in the religious part. If you
convert to Judaism religiously, you are religiously
Jewish. But that obviously doesn't change
your ethnicity. So I'm ethnically Jewish,
I identify with Jewish cultural history, et
cetera.
But I am not personally a religious person.
If that would be concerning to you. Let me
allay your fears. I am not a religious person.
A another post, the Sam Seder Rip off is getting
out of control. This is so funny. Someone
there are a whole bunch of, uh, and I posted
these to the David Pakman show Instagram and
to my own, there are a bunch of photoshops
being done, uh, that make our set look even
more like Sam Seder's set and someone actually,
uh, digitally added glasses to my face that
looked like Sam's and also gave me a receding
hairline digitally of course, which I don't
even actually know that Sam has a receding
hairline. When I sent them the image, he found
it funny and I said, I don't actually think
you have that receding hairline. He said he
does. Um, and it is, don't worry, I'm not
going to be going out of my way to adopt more
elements of Sam Seder's Look, uh, if anyone
is concerned that we're going in that direction.
Also from the David Pakman show, sub Reddit,
some of you may have noticed that on Monday
we launched a new thumbnail design for our
youtube and Facebook video thumbnails. If
you listen to the podcast or watch the show
on TV or listen on the radio, you wouldn't
even notice this. But for those who have a,
I did get a post on the subreddit saying that
the new thumbnails are less appealing. Are
you one of our users does not like the new
thumbnails. Uh, and fortunately most people
do. And I really like them. I think it's a
great new design developed by David Pakman
show producer and business development associate
Noah Ferguson. And the feedback has been overwhelmingly
positive and you know, I always have to remember
anytime we change anything on the show, I
will disproportionately here from people who
dislike it. And that's just the nature of
a feedback and reviews.
It's a phenomenon that's widely, uh, um, uh,
sort of explored on the Internet. And in this
case the feedback has been overwhelmingly
positive. So accounting for the fact that
people who hate something are much more likely
to reach out to me. I am confident that in
total new thumbnails are a good thing and
a, they're looking really good. Join the discussion@davidpakman.com
slash r e d d. I t nearly 10,000 of our viewers
and listeners are now participating in political
discussions there the discussions are moderated
to ensure that there is not bullying and toxicity
that we, uh, don't look at very kindly at
the David Pakman show. So you can be confident
that your ideas will be welcomed respectfully
and if they aren't, you let me know personally
and I'll make sure that that's taken care
of.